so you're in college right now and you
want to get into data science that's
good
i'm going to talk to you about that and
maybe even give you some helpful tips
i'm richard and this is richard on data
[Music]
so the very first thing that i'm going
to state in this video is that if you're
not in college or you don't have a
degree
you can still break into data science in
fact i have a whole video all about that
but there's no question that degree is
going to help you land that first job as
well as to make more money down the road
not to mention that based on totally
unscientific polling i've done on my own
channel most of my viewers appear to be
in college right now so it's good that
you have your eyes on the prize in this
video i'm going to share with you the
considerations i would carry with you in
order to set yourself up for success as
best as possible
before i do that though i would humbly
ask that you subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already and also take just a
fraction of a second to smash the like
button because that really does help my
content reach a larger audience then if
you want to chip in above and beyond
that to support my channel i'll have
links in the description of this video
to my paypal and patreon accounts as
well as to my crypto wallet addresses
also please note that i'm not a licensed
or professional career advisor or
anything of that nature so please take
this video for some helpful food for
thought as well as for entertainment
purposes
so the very first tip i'm going to give
is going to go for absolutely everybody
it doesn't matter what program or school
you're in it doesn't matter what major
you're in it doesn't even matter if
you're going into data science or not
and that tip is to carry with you a
sense of humility i've seen it happen
many times where somebody gets a degree
from a top-notch university
and then they somehow think that this
entitles them to things or that it's
automatically a guarantee of ongoing
success
if that's you you may very well get
thrown into real world problems and get
smacked in the face
because it's often when you get out of
college and you start solving real
problems for real businesses that you
learn exactly how much you don't
actually know yet
learning really is a forever process and
college is a great first step at that
but it really is just a first step and
you don't get a shortcut or a pass on
the rest of the process of learning just
because you have a really good degree
now that we've got that one out of the
way let's actually talk about leveraging
your college or university to acquire
the necessary skill sets that being said
i would be lying to you if i told you
there weren't companies that will
automatically exclude you if you don't
have a particular major
and the most common types of majors that
fit into this umbrella are statistics
computer science information technology
pure data science
maybe economics and business but then
what are the actual skills you need to
develop for data science
first of all you absolutely need to have
some exposure to statistics this is
going to be your foundation and now i
did a video all about how much
statistics you need and the link will be
in the description to that but the
reason i call it the foundation is
because it gives you different methods
for attacking problems and it helps you
reason through problems it helps you
understand all the underlying
considerations with real world problems
and it prevents you from delving into
pseudoscience it keeps what you're doing
actually scientific then you should also
ideally get some course work in on
databases and multi-relational data
structures
in particular something that's going to
cover sql you don't need to go crazy
with this necessarily but if you can
learn sql in the course of your college
education it's really going to pay
dividends for you some computer science
is also going to serve you really well
so at least from my experience usually
when you learn one programming language
it makes it significantly easier to
learn the next one
so don't stress out too much over the
specific language that you're learning
but if you get some exposure to python
that's that's even more awesome and
while you're at it if you get some
exposure to microsoft azure or aws
that's going to be really helpful too
now the next tip i'm going to give at
this point is to be a little bit
cautious with professors it's been my
experience anyway that there are
professors out there who are amazing but
there are also those who've been stuck
in academia for 30 plus years they've
gotten themselves into a bit of a bubble
and then they design their courses like
academic exercises those are usually the
types of courses that you end up using
and remembering nothing from it might be
help to talk to departmental counselors
or other people that you trust to figure
out which professors came from recent
industrial experience
even if those are actually lecturers who
probably get paid a lot less than full
tenure tracked professors
there's a good chance you'll learn a lot
more from those courses and that they'll
be a lot more practical yes i understand
this is not something always that you
have a lot of flexibility with for
instance sometimes your program will
require certain courses you don't get to
choose your professor but when you're
picking things like electives it's
certainly something to think about
keeping up with the theme of doing true
practical things you want to get the
chance to do some real project work i
know everybody hates group projects but
these really are some of the absolute
best learning experiences that you can
get for real-world data science when
you're in college don't be that person
who sits back never shows up to meetings
and lets your whole team do all the work
you're shortchanging yourself on a lot
of valuable learning experiences and
plus your whole team is going to hate
you you want to be actually really
trying in these projects and then at the
end saving and holding on to your final
work keep a jupiter notebook or r
markdown file or at least a word
document or something
then document the problem that you were
working on the code the solution you
came up with and then interpret that in
real world terms
even if you're somebody looking for a
job with zero work experience up to this
point even being able to do something
like this is going to give you a leg up
over other people and i guarantee you
it's going to impress people that you
talk with a lot more than some final
grade that you get in some arbitrary
class
if you literally don't get any chances
whatsoever to do projects like this your
next best bet would probably be to go to
kaggle and do some challenges there but
you want to at least have something
tangible that you can talk about on your
resume or on your linkedin profile
even better yet a little portfolio with
code that you've written that can go
somewhere like github now as far as
actually looking for a job is concerned
you want to be looking at the market as
soon as possible the first reason for
that is you want to get an internship if
you can
there's plenty of companies out there
that love to hire interns they're way
cheaper than regular full-time employees
and they're really helpful for just
getting stuff off the company's plate
and frankly there is a pretty well-known
catch-22 situation with a lot of
companies out there that is you need to
have experience to get a job but you
can't get a job sometimes because you
don't have experience first if you're
able to get around that problem by let's
say in your sophomore or junior year or
certainly if you're in grad school
getting an internship during the summer
that's going to pay off massively for
you
especially if you get a chance at that
internship to actually write code and
just keep building that portfolio out
so now the last major thing i would say
here is to really figure out how much
college you actually need just speaking
personally on this one when i was part
way through my bachelor's degree i was
looking at jobs in my local area and i
found out that a huge number of them
either outright required a master's
degree or at least stated that it was a
strong preference of theirs
sadly that has become a recent trend
where master's degrees are highly
preferred for a lot of jobs
but that is subject to change based on
macroeconomic factors and there are tons
of exceptions to that rule google being
a pretty obvious example where they
overtly care nothing about your degree
and personally this is just me but i
didn't want to be a broke college
student then go out and make money then
leave that job only to go back and live
like a broke college student again
i wanted to get all that school out of
the way so that i'd never have to go
back to it again but ultimately that's a
completely personal decision that only
you can make but you still want to make
the most informed possible decision that
you can and that's where getting a feel
for the market is going to help you
whether that's through sites like
linkedin or indeed and increasingly in
this post-pandemic era you may also be
able to find remote jobs in other states
or locations
so that's probably something you want to
consider above and beyond your own local
area if you're okay with working in a
remote capacity if you see a lot of
positions out there that require just a
bachelor's there's absolutely no reason
to feel obligated or forced to get a
master's or especially a phd i should
tell you in full transparency that those
advanced degrees are going to increase
your likelihood of finding jobs and
netting a higher salary but they
absolutely are not required it's all
just a game of probabilities so those
are all of my tips for breaking into
data science for college students
or i should say a combination of things
i personally did that worked as well as
some other things that i wish i had done
if you're going to go to college in the
first place do it right
don't be one of those people who gets
out with nothing to show for it but a
pile of student loan debt regrets and
maybe even some liver damage
sure have some fun while you're at it i
know i did but if you're interested in
data science and you're already paying
for college that means you're probably
surrounded with learning opportunities
all around you whether you realize them
or not the final gpa that you have at
the end probably doesn't matter nearly
as much as you think in fact the name of
the college or university that you're at
also probably isn't going to matter much
in the long run
but the learning opportunities that you
get assuming you truly learn the
necessary material
that is going to carry with you into the
future probably more so than you can
even imagine
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it smash the like button it only
takes about a half a second
and then leave me a comment down below
let me know what you think
did you agree with my points here
anything that you disagreed with let me
know
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then
richard
on data